hi I'm drew I'm the producer on Titan
fall and titanfall 2 and we decided to
do these things throughout the last bit
of development on time felt too we
really appreciate all the feedback we
get from our fans and we won't be where
we are today without them so we want to
give you guys a little bit more of an
insight into how we make the game some
of the decisions we've made along the
way we learned a lot during titanfall
one there's a lot of experience games
there a lot of lessons learned and we've
been rolling a lot of that into
titanfall to you know making a
multiplier only game on titanfall
onement our tire job was to make our
community happy so we did a whole bunch
of post-release content we look to a
bunch of stats and we really listened to
you guys so some of the stuff we're
going to be covering these digital
shorts are things like how we're hosting
servers because we're changing that up a
little bit from last time we're changing
a lot of our matchmaking system so you
can find better games quicker we've
added this awesome new thing called
networks that allows you to make groups
of friends and play together a lot
easier and also probably some of the
more gameplay or to stuff like some of
our progression system changes and
things like that but really this is for
the more hardcore fans out there these
people who really want to know some more
than a degree of how our games are made
so these are not marketing speak this
isn't anything other than actual game
developers telling you how we're doing
our job so hope you guys enjoy and
there'll be a lot more of these to come
if you have anything you want us to
cover let us know tweet at us Facebook
us instagramers I assume we have all
those just let us know what you want to
hear about and we'll do our best to
cover for you thanks